have you read to be Moore's new memoir
inside out I did I read it in a day yes
what did you think
very very juicy very interesting that
you're also her doppelganger I think
people do tell me that and they actually
post a better book in the gym reposted
it which made me very excited that my
doppelganger reposted my post I love
this so much well her daughter's rumored
Tallulah joined to me for Monday's
episode of read Table Talk and in this
exclusive sneak peak rumor calls a
moment she found her mom in the midst of
an overdose I was there in the other
room with nine-one-one panicking we need
an ambulance I'm like either my mom's
gonna die and I'm not gonna be in the
room and I'm gonna feel the guilt of
that for the rest of my life or I'm
gonna be there and see this image of my
mom and that I will never get out of my
head so that's what I do
or I'm gonna have to call my sisters in
the morning and tell them that my mom
died and they're never gonna talk to her
again as demi looked on at the red table
sombrely rumor relived that impossible
choice in 2012 can you hear me she can't
speak the 9-1-1 call was placed during
Damis relapse into alcohol abuse that
day she had been partying with rumor and
suffered a seizure from smoking
synthetic cannabis and inhaling nitrous
oxide the conversation also includes
Damis 25 year old daughter Tallulah she
described a jekyll-and-hyde
transformation when Tammy used it was
like the Sun went down and like like a
monster came I could sense like her eyes
shutting a little bit more the way she
was speaking or she would be a lot more
affectionate with me if she wasn't sober
and I it was jarring and Moore's memoir
she said it took a lot of work to
rebuild the relationship with her three
daughters once she got sober Demi
recently told us having their support
now has meant everything I feel so much
gratitude and and just joy it's just
that's it
you can catch Demi's full episode on
this Monday's episode of a read tabletop
on Facebook watch
[Music]